voici les chiffres du jour pour le
Québec 323 km
de natation de ces 6 années 88
pourquoi le discours semble vraiment
très nerveux en tout cas du côté du
gouvernement du Québec
[Musique]
on vient souvent avec la même
l'arrivée du bien
d'avoir une augmentation très très
rapide
actrice un peu pour ça qu'on a donné que
tu
ne pourras plus travailler
chant de personnel 2 - 12 est déjà à
court de personnel
il y a deux choses que j'aimerais
beaucoup de personnes
c'est une façon de sa sœur
[Musique]
exactement
dernière personne qui peuvent faire une
différence
un emploi
au Québec
74 % et 75 %
pour 2
beaucoup plus dangereux
beaucoup plus mal
[Musique]
c'est chaque pourcentage de plus ça me
fait plaisir de 85
ans
catégorie personne